there is a war raging and the world is
taking sides but they don't want to get
involved with troops and guns so they're
turning to a new weapon an invisible one
a weapon that is only possible because
of our deeply connected world economy
sanctions
sanctions
sanctions are this thing that just get
thrown around like we should all just
understand what they mean but sanctions
are a kind of wonky bureaucratic tool
for economic war and they're not super
easy to understand unless you crack them
open and look at the mechanics of how
they work and that's what i want to do
today i want to explain what sanctions
actually are what their goal is and
whether or not they actually work so
let's go the largest and most severe
package of economic sanctions that
russia has ever seen
before we dive into this video i quickly
want to pause for a commercial break and
thank today's sponsor who made this
video possible thank you betterhelp for
sponsoring this video betterhelp is a
place that is making therapy more
accessible to everyone securely on the
internet i'm a huge fan of therapy i've
been doing therapy for two and a half
years and i really believe in better
help's mission in making therapy more
accessible finding a therapist is not
easy and often when you need therapy the
most you're not in the best head space
to sit around and call a bunch of people
and call your insurance and figure out
how to get a therapist with better help
you take a quiz you get matched with
someone in their huge network of
licensed therapists and you can start
communicating with someone right away
within like 48 hours this is not a
crisis line or a self-help program this
is like real legitimate therapy done
securely on the internet you can try
this out for a discounted rate at the
link in my description betterhelp.com
johnny harris where you'll get 10 off
your first month you can try it out and
see if this is a good fit for you i love
therapy it just changed my life maybe it
could do the same for you thank you
better help for supporting my channel
and supporting this video let's dive
into sanctions
[Music]
in the most literal sense
sanctions are
this
a piece of paper a bunch of lists that
governments make that is what sanctions
are bureaucratic lists but this is a
weapon of war it looks a little bit
different than the kinds of weapons
we're used to seeing in war but this is
a weapon i am looking at a list of
hundreds and hundreds of names
people's names and their addresses as
well as their aliases their birthdays
their tax id numbers and anyone else
that is also on the list that they might
be linked to here in the us this list
comes from an office that is focused on
thinking about things that come in and
out of our country sanctions are also
this this comes from the white house and
instead of people's names it has
industries and products like crude oil
and liquefied natural gas and coal and
alcoholic beverages and diamonds and
luxury goods and that is the point here
what sanctions are is a giant list of
people and things that are not allowed
to come into our country or whatever
country is writing the sanction oh and
the list includes
the sale of
u.s bank notes like cash like you're not
allowed to send like a pallet of cash to
the russian government according to joe
biden okay but here's where it gets
interesting i want to tell you how all
these boring lists of paper that were
drafted up in the past few weeks
actually translate into economic war
what is happening right now in the
global economy it's totally invisible
it's not like tanks and guns you can't
see it but it's having a huge effect and
i want to show you what that looks like
the best way to do this is to look at
russia before all of these sanctions you
can see that russia is connected to the
world in a lot of different ways i've
color-coded them for you blue is
everything that russia exports to other
countries like oil gold coal orange is
everything flowing the other way stuff
that russia imports like iphones from
the us or cars from germany that's
orange green is all of the money that
needs to flow in and out of russia to
keep things running that's money that
businesses borrow from foreign banks or
it's money that the russian government
has put into us dollars or euros so that
they have reserves in case they need it
we'll call this the financial stuff but
then there's personal wealth which we'll
put in purple one of the best parts
about being a russian billionaire is
that you can spend millions and millions
of dollars on a flat in london or paris
or you can buy a yacht that you station
in the port in the south of france
russian billionaires have money and
assets all around the world that they
use as their global playground and then
of course there's just regular russians
people who fly around the world for
tourism and business on airlines that
are from many different countries those
airlines fly over russia in russian
airspace to get to a variety of
destinations so yeah russia is connected
like we all are to the global economy we
trade we move around and everyone
thrives it's great but then russia
invades ukraine a few weeks ago we are
coming on the air because the war in
ukraine has begun
[Music]
this is totally unacceptable says the
whole world we want to retaliate and
show putin that we can't do that we have
to set a precedent that you're not
allowed to invade your neighbor but we
can't send troops like we used to in the
old days because now we all have these
big weapons that could destroy our
species so we can't like start fighting
with each other directly so what do we
do i know says all the angry western
leaders let's start to mess with all of
this that'll teach him welcome to
economic war which again like i said
starts like this a bunch of bureaucrats
making lists of people and things and
vessels that are now not allowed in
their country
but the hope is that it creates a domino
effect that changes the course of this
war and let me show you how that might
look
okay so this is russia happily connected
to the global economy
these sanctions target every one of
these connections like let's just look
at imports one of the first things the
eu did was ban their countries from
selling luxury goods to russia so the
eu's like yeah like we're pro-ukraine
like we're drafting up these sanctions
to hurt russian billionaires and then
out of nowhere italy crops up and is
like uh yeah can we get an exemption
like can we sell our goods because we
have like
gucci and armani and
come on and they actually got an
exemption and then people were like wait
no we're not giving you an exemption
just because you have all these fancy
designers like come on italy get with it
and italy was like ugh fine but it
wasn't just the eu who started cutting
off these connections singapore banned
their people from selling electronics
and computers and taiwan where all the
microchips are made banned their
companies from selling those microchips
to russia which is a giant deal because
microchips are in everything
hundreds of international companies that
were in russia started to read the tea
leaves and they're like we're out of
here like imagine if mcdonald's and ikea
and apple all left your city and then
netflix announced that it no longer is
streaming in your country all in the
same week like this is real punishment
this is what economic war looks like
okay so that's imports the same thing
starts happening the other way russia is
a giant exporter of oil and gas and all
sorts of fossil fuels and so the west
trying to inflict punishment on russia
bans their countries from importing
russian oil and gas that is a huge blow
to russia like the second biggest
exporter of refined and unrefined
petroleum on earth the economic war is
heating up and in the middle of all of
this vladimir putin gets up and
announces that he sees this as an act of
war and that he is putting his nuclear
weapons on high alert as a response
like this is real war tactics we're
talking about here with real
consequences all right let's get to the
fun sanctions like watching rich people
squirm
[Music]
back to this list that the government
made of russians who they really don't
like
[Music]
those people now cannot travel to our
country and any country whose list they
are on and any money that they had in
our country like if they had it in an
american bank is now frozen they can't
touch it like it's totally inaccessible
to them their yachts and their private
jets if they're in our jurisdiction can
be seized everyone on this list is now a
target and there are hundreds of them in
fact i've been deep in the o fact
sanctions list there are 712 russians on
this list in case you wanted to know
it's all there on the ofac website so
going through this list you kind of get
curious you're like who are these people
i now know their birthday and their
address and all of their aliases but
like who are they are these war
criminals are they like military
generals or something well no there's
actually a few categories here the
biggest one is probably russian
lawmakers there are not 300 of them that
are now sanctioned but then you have a
bunch of rich russians who are the heads
of defense energy and media companies i
see make the most powerful russians
uncomfortable and hopefully they'll turn
against putin and get him to stop the
war that's the logic and then you have
this 26 year old instagram star who's
also on the sanctions list wait what ah
yes polina
the daughter of the very rich foreign
minister of russia who lives a very
fancy life in london
and the uk sees this and they're like no
you've got blood on your hands too put
her on the list and she's on the list
and now she can't travel to london where
she has a bunch of money and she has a
big fancy flat and she's stuck in russia
she's on the list this is happening to
hundreds of rich russian people and like
we don't know if all of them are
connected to vladimir putin we're just
like you're super rich and influential
so we're gonna make your life hard
please change this speaking of travel
tons of countries have written sanctions
that ban russian airlines from entering
their airspace and tons of airlines have
cut their routes to russia so now the
flow of people just human beings
tourists and business travelers has come
to a screeching halt okay finally the
last category is big money this is
actually like the hardest one to see and
understand but maybe the biggest and
most important you have to understand
that the russian government holds on to
tons of reserves in other currencies
like dollars and euros and
british pounds they do this because if
their currency the rupal falls they can
take their dollars and buy a bunch of
rupals and raise the price back up and
stabilize it but now all of their
foreign reserves their euros and dollars
are frozen in like american and like
british banks
the russian government can't get their
hands on their money in other countries
okay but the finance thing gets crazier
russian banks were then kicked out of
the system where banks can send giant
amounts of money to each other it's
called swift they were kicked out now
they have to route all their big
payments through like china which is
like their one friend in all of this and
one more on the finance piece regular
russians can't use their credit cards
anymore or their debit cards because
visa mastercard american express all
pulled out of russia like that would
suck so all of this is to say that
russia went from looking like this to
looking like this
totally isolated and that was the goal
to isolate russia from the global
economy and make them feel pressure on
all levels the people the oligarchs the
government the military the hope here is
that the rich russian billionaires who
have a lot of influence in politics as
well as the people who are now suffering
because they can't get in on the global
economy they will all look to putin and
be like dude enough we're done so the
question is
will it work well it depends on what
your definition of work is in terms of
creating economic pain yes it's already
working i mean look at how hard the
rupal crashed after the war started
because remember the government can't
get its hands on all of its foreign
reserves to help stabilize their
currency the moscow stock exchange
closed down for weeks the economy is
shrinking there is scarcity in russia
but for me the definition of will this
work is will this change vladimir
putin's mind to get him to stop fighting
this stupid war and that's a question i
do not know the answer to because
sanctions are not like normal weapons
we've had guns and missiles and bombs
for a long time we know how they work we
know how they deter people we know who
they hurt
but sanctions are not that old they're
as old as our fairly new global economic
order we make these lists and put on
these bans for travel and industries and
financial systems and we just sort of
hope that the ripple effect makes it to
vladimir putin's brain but i'm just not
sure putin is a rational actor anymore
and that is the contradiction of
sanctions
is usually we put sanctions on countries
like north korea these pariah states
where the leader is not a rational actor
anymore they're bent on some weird
ideological vision they're surrounded by
a bunch of yes men and so sanctions turn
into just another narrative that they
can use to say we are the victims we are
embattled the rest of the world is at
war with us plus frankly russia still
has a way out of some of these sanctions
china is still their ally in this
and china is deeply connected to the
world economy oh and also do we really
think that russian billionaires are
going to be stopped by a list from a
bunch of bureaucrats these people are
well resourced they're going to find
ways to get around the sanctions whether
it's shell companies or middlemen or
whatever it's just going to be a little
less convenient for them so in the end
it's the russian people who are going to
suffer the most here
well
that is after the real victims of this
whole thing the ukrainian people who
have had their country senselessly
stolen from them
[Music]
you